stéphanie grammond christian dufour alec
castonguay bonsoir je le disais en début
d'émission deux ans presque jour pour
jour après la mort tragique de cette
petite fille de sept ans qui avait la
mort qui avait indigné le québec on a le
rapport laurent volumineux je veux
entendre madame le rat qui ne nous dit
oui ça va prendre des ressources issa
vont prendre du temps mais voici où il
faut aller mais pour nous on ne peut pas
le choix que d'entamer se virent à
adopter des choses qu'on peut mettre en
place plus rapidement
mais quand on parle par exemple des
intervenantes qu'il faut valoriser leur
travail
il faut diminuer la charge de travail on
est très conscient qu'on oppose une
baguette magique de même hâte et mardi
ce sera parfait mais cependant ce qui
est clair c'est qu'on a l'obligation d'y
travailler ça on au port ne s'en sort
pas nos choix et il faut travailler avec
les gens qui sont sur le terrain
il faut travailler avec les
gestionnaires pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on voit diminuer cette charge de
travail qui est trop lourde
aider les intervenantes d'une part et
beaucoup plus de prévention en amont
d'autre part à la question qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de ce rapport mais je
trouve que c'est une formidable carte
routière pour le gouvernement parce
qu'on a vraiment été dans toutes sortes
de détails du tribunal unifie pour les
enfants jusqu'à la création d'un
commissaire au bien-être et au droit des
enfants
l'adoption simple donc faciliter le fait
qu'on puisse adopter un enfant
la dpj qui est pas de tout le temps des
va et vient entre la famille d'adoption
pile la famille biologique c'est un gros
problème pour les enfants au québec donc
faciliter une certaine stabilité donc on
va dans beaucoup de domaines il ya
évidemment pile régine laurent il fait
allusion le ddd des secteurs où ce sera
plus long le valoriser le travail des
intervenants diminuer leur charge de
travail à embaucher ce serait un peu le
même problème qu'on a pour les
infirmiers pour les préposés aux
bénéficiaires à des postes où on peut
attirer les gens ont moins le goût de
d'occuper ça sera beaucoup plus long
terme mais dans l'ensemble je pense que
c'est un rapport qui qui a redirigé
absolument aucun aspect l'on a bien fait
le travail du côté des jeunes le raid
son équipe le rapport embrasse large
parce que la prévention je le répète on
parle et c'est l'essai on parle des
écoles plus de psychologues donc c'est
il y en a pour tout le monde un titien
oui moi je partage pas l'enthousiasmé
dalet qui trop embrasse mal mal étreint
j'écoute attentivement madame leur ré
madame beuvrages et j'ai eu du tout les
choses
aujourd'hui les deux nouvelles qui
ressortent c'est un révélateur c'est la
nomination d'un commissaire au droit et
au bien-être de l'enfant par l'assemblée
nationale jour parce que ça va changer
pour le bien-être des enfants qui sont
maltraités aussi à l'adoption d'une
charte des droits de l'enfant je suis je
peux avoir l'air cynique le maire
faisait ce qu'on pense
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était beaucoup de
lieux communs de bons sentiments de
parole on dit roman dans le jargon
bureaucratique québécois très très bien
pensants je trouve que pas de diagnostic
ce qui est arrivé avant des [ __ ]
habilité je trouve que tellement de
choses que s'est t'il à savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils proposent concrètement j'ai noté
ce que les participations concertation
collaboration prévention interdite
bien de travail en silo projet de
société société solidaire et inclusive
bienveillance
moi je crois pas beaucoup à ça je trouve
que ça me rappelait en fait le domaine
de la santé où on est fait entre en face
une culture bureaucratique très bien
pensants très bienveillant qu'il a
discuté accouché de choses concrètes
je sais que je suis sûrs mais c'est ça
que je m'accrocherai sont trop larges et
tellement large que ses paroles pas je
pensais la chanson de dalida paroles
moi ce qui m'a frappé à la lecture du
rapport qui effectivement touffu c'est
que il ya beaucoup d'outils qui existe
déjà mais qu'ils sont mal utilisés il ya
beaucoup de recommandations qui sont
faites qui ne sont pas nouvelles mais
qui ont déjà été faites par une dizaine
d'autres commissions comités un groupe
d'experts qui ont été mandatés dans au
fil des décennies par le gouvernement
pour essayer de trouver des solutions et
guérir la dpj donc c'est pas nouveau et
et dans le passé les recommandations ont
été faites malheureusement comme le
tribunal une fille essaie depuis les
années 70 ce qu'on en parle comment ça
se fait que c'est pas encore réalisé ce
qu'on espère c'est que le ya une volonté
politique peut-être que justement cette
tragédie leur qui s'est produite avec la
petite fille de green bay va avoir cet
effet l'aude de motiver le gouvernement
à mettre les choses en place et ce qui
manque c'est évidemment il manque de
l'argent mais il manque aussi je crois
un porteur de ballon et on sent ce mois
je crois que l'idée d'un commissaire et
est loin d'être bête est déjà une
directrice de la protection de la
jeunesse qui a été nommé par québec
c'était une des recommandations le dieu
du rapport préliminaire la commission
leur en oeuvre alors ça c'est déjà fait
elle est entrée en poste en mars et il
yad'autres d'autres recommandations qui
ont déjà été mises en place sans que
plus d'argent aux groupes communautaires
et qui s'occupe des familles
ecce terra québec à l'intention de
déposer un projet de loi et on peut se
permettre d'être optimiste même si on
voit que dans le passé effectivement il
ya beaucoup ces recommandations sont
tombés ou est rapidement agression moi
je trouve qu aucune remise en question
des façons de procéder québécoise
commence à devenir un petit pic en fait
quand on a des dossiers liés à notre
administration publique
on nous parle beaucoup et de deux je
sais que suis sûr notre cas on nous
parle de l'importance de remettre
l'enfant au coeur juste un jeu c'est la
bureaucratie qu et ça ressort très
clairement
moi j'aurais aimé avoir chaud de +12
plus clair qu'ils disent dans le passé
et eu des problèmes à cause de sa sauce
soya des responsables on propose de
faire çà çà çà l'oeil
c'est une analyse qui semait
intellectuelle de niveau doctorat sur le
problème sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
avec un dernier mot là dessus sur
l'adoption simple qui est proposé qui
décolle du fait qu'on veut faciliter la
stabilité pour les enfants qui sont
déracinés parce que leur milieu il
dangereux ou pas des quoi et la sas et
on le dit de différentes façons on veut
changer la loi
ça pourrait être une avancée concrète là
ça pourrait être une avancée concrète ça
veut pas dire évidemment de couper le
lien entre bon la famille biologique et
l'enfant lemay d'arrêter de les
transvaser le côté à l'autre pendant des
années parce que mon et le lien affectif
de l'enfant n'est ni pour une famille
adoptive ni pour sa famille biologique
puis se retrouve émotivement brisée puis
sacré d'autres problèmes dont la
stabilité dans l'enfance et motive c'est
très important ça c'est intéressant -
moi j'suis d'accord avec stéphanie la
nomination d'un commissaire au bien-être
et au droit des enfants
ça existe dans d'autres provinces qui
ont un nom différent ça existe par
exemple au nouveau brunswick
chaque année un rapport qui est déposé à
l'assemblée nationale ça fait des
articles dans les journaux ça fait des
reportages à la télé ça force les élus à
faire des diagnostics à ce qu'on se fait
surveiller au gouvernement on fait plus
attention c'est pour ainsi de la
vérificatrice générale du protecteur du
citoyen alors d'en avoir un qui s'occupe
des enfants ça serait pas de trop et lui
pourrait voir ce que ces recommandations
là qui sont effectivement pour l'instant
des belles paroles question raison faut
en appliquer quelques jeunes alors
moment donné il faut ça prend quelqu'un
qui surveille tout sauf que moi je pense
que c'est une idée intéressante et de
faciliter la vie aux intervenantes ceci
ce n'est pas faire je pense qu'on manque
le bateau collectivement il faut que les
intervenantes soient mieux traitées je
vais pas dire un salaire mais avoir des
moyens que leur nombre de cas soit
diminués c'est très complexe et tout ça
on verra ce que le ministre van dire
demain réagit en grèce on pourrait
commencer par leur donner des
cellulaires ce serait déjà une avancée
possible des adjointes administratives
comme l'a dit madame ok très bien
monsieur legault et l'émigration écoute
ce qu'il a dit aux gens d'affaires
c'était devant une réunion zoom vendredi
il veut des immigrants mais qu'ils vont
gagner plus que 56 mais l'on est comme
moi mon obsession c'est d'augmenter
salaire moyen au québec
donc à chaque fois que je rentre un
immigrant qui gagnent moins de cinquante
six mille j'en paye mon problème à
chaque fois que j'entends un immigrant
qui gagnent plus que cinquante six mille
j'améliore ma situation
si à chaque fois qu'on rend un immigrant
économique
le fédéral nous oblige à rentrer un
réfugié ou une réunification familiale
mais là on voir des difficultés à aller
chercher les bonnes personnes
alors contexte juste avant de donner la
parole c'est fanny monsieur legault
weaver augmenter un peu les seuils mais
absolument pas de l'ordre que voudraient
certains représentants comme le conseil
du patronat qui voudraient 70 mail par
année ça sera pas du tout ça ces
familles que tout j'avais passé de 2,7
ce plaidoyer de monsieur ghosn mais en
fait ou ce que je crois c'est que si on
veut une relance économique
ça va prendre les bras si on veut
remettre nos finances publiques en ordre
ça va prendre des gens pour payer des
impôts en nous au québec la population
vieillit alors il n'y a pas de mystère
puis le québec ne citerai ville parce
que dans son budget les chiffres de les
prévisions de croissance d'emploi sont
anémiques et donc c'est un aveu de 10 il
y aura pas énormément de croissance de
l'emploi à moins que il ya plus
d'immigration et voyons des économistes
parlons qui calcule que si on veut
seulement maintenir notre poids
démographique au québec dans le à
l'intérieur du canada
ça nous prendrait 70000 immigrants par
année
bon alors quand la cac était en fait il
est à 50 mille îles ont baissé à 40
mines 25 parce qu'il y avait évidemment
la fin des mileux savoir remonter jusqu
où ça devrait aller
bon le débat est ouvert mais ce qu'il
faut voir aussi c'est au delà du nombre
qui est ce qu on veut accueillir
est ce que en ce moment on a presque la
moitié des immigrants qui sombra qui ont
un diplôme universitaire sauf que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est beaucoup
dans des postes techniques qui demande
une formation technique donc dans la
construction des infirmières est chez
terra alors peut-être que ça vaudrait la
peine de regarder aussi de ce côté là
plutôt que des diplômés universitaires
qui arrivent et qui ont des emplois qui
sont complètement en dessous de leurs
compétences
peut-être qu'il faudrait envoyer plus de
gens en région parce qu'il manque
d'emplois là aussi d'avoir davantage
d'entrepreneurs m'avoir aidé des jeunes
et des étudiants qu'on peut conserver
ici au pays ou au québec parce que ces
gens là sont déjà intégrés alors c'est
toutes ces solutions il faut regarder
avec la défense du premier ministre
s'était pas un exposé de tout
d'immigration du gouvernement du québec
qu'il faisait au genre d'affaires c'est
très ciblée autour de l'immigration
économique
je trouve que les extraits qu'on en a vu
une simplification à outrance du
phénomène c'est à dire que le plus gros
problème du québec là c'est d'attirer
des travailleurs étrangers qui ont une
formation adéquate pour combler les
besoins du marché et a jamais été
question en fait du salaire parce qu'on
peut avoir besoin d'un soudeur à 38
mille dollars par année
il va tout à fait bien s'intégrer au
québec qui va avoir son emploi en
arrivant l'espèce de deux critères plus
subjectifs du bus scolaires moyens à
56000 de leurs là même le gouvernement
ne prêche par l'exemple
quant au crible françois legault ces
postes de préposés aux bénéficiaires et
fixé la barre à 49 mille dollars en 10
ans mais je pense que c'est suffisant
pour attirer des gens dans ce domaine là
il ya eu raison il ya plein de gens qui
ont acquis on avions appliqué pour
donner préposés aux bénéficiaires n'y a
pas mis la barre à 56 mille dollars
les entreprises ont une échelle de
salaire à respecter pour rester
compétitive pour être capable de tirer
leur épingle du jeu par rapport aux
concurrents au québec au canada à
l'étranger donc c'est sûr que la
pression sur les entreprises de monter
salaire étant donné la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre elle est forte mais en
même temps c'est pas juste une question
de salaires le gouvernement peut pas
dire ben attirer des gens au de 56000 il
ya des domaines où ça s'applique - puis
on a quand même besoin c'est une oeuvre
qui eux s'attendent à ce que les comment
les ied en attirer leurs essais se pose
pas le message envoyé mais quand
monsieur le groupe poursuit puis 10 moi
je veux pas chaque fois que je j'accepte
un immigrants économiques entre
guillemets est obligé de prendre un
réfugié en même temps donc on voit
christian que le le plafond ne veut il
ne veut pas le placer trop pour
l'immigration
oui c'est ça suis le chalet est un peu
mal à l'aise quand même par le fait que
monsieur legault parlait quand même à
coeur ouvert
donc ne postez pas 107 public puis
quelqu'un que j'ai bon en fait
d'enregistrer sa plus de couler ça moi
ça me choque encore un peu le jeu doit
être si vous êtes d'accord c'est
d'intérêt public
c'est vrai c'est vrai je veux dire quand
même parce que je trouve que j avais
beaucoup beaucoup de monde mais c'est
vrai vous avez raison que c'est
intéressant parce qu'on n'a pas en fait
ce que pense candidement
monsieur legault par rapport à ce thème
là et puis au fond monsieur legault
comme les québécois ils confrontés à un
problème dont la solution est pas
évidente
comme le dit stéphanie bon sur le plan
strictement économique on n'a pas
vraiment le choix on sait que le
vieillissement de la population on a
vraiment besoin beaucoup d'immigrants on
a reçoit déjà quand même beaucoup faut
gratter quelques et baic est une des
sociétés qui reçoit le plus d'immigrants
au monde par rapport à sa population
leur musique faudra recevoir beaucoup
plus le président du conseil du patronat
paraître 70000 je pars donc monsieur
legault je pense qu'on voit que il veut
peu freiné parce que aussi les autres
considérations
le français de capacités d'intégration
ça fait partie du portrait aussi au pas
de solution mais on sent que monsieur
legault n'est pas pour l'immigration
tout azimut il ya des espèces de réserve
pour l'heure je trouve que ça confirme
ce qu'on a souvent dit le slogan
il veut vraiment avoir des gens qui sont
bien payés qui ont dessalé concert
merci à vous trois merci à vous trois
bonnes soirées au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit